تطورات ميدانيه اخرى قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان القوه الروسيه استهدفت
الاراضي الاوكرانيه باربع ضربات صاروخيه
خلال الساعات الماضيه
58 غاره جويه على المواقع العسكريه
الاوكرانيه والمناطق السكنيه
واضافت هيئه الاركان في بيان ان قوتها
الجويه اسقطت خمسه مسيرات من نوع شاهد
وخمسا اخرى استطلاعيه
ونفذت اثنتي عشره غاره على مواقع القوات
الروسيه ومخازن ذخيرتها
معنى من دونيتس مراسل الجزيره نور الدين
كما ينضم الينا من سلوفيانس كمراسل
الجزيره مازن ابراهيم وابدا معك مازن
وتفاصيل التطورات الاخيره بالتحديد هذا
القصف الصاروخي على مدينتي اوديسا وخاركيف
نعم سهام وحسن من الواضح انه بالنسبه
للقياده الاوكرانيه فان الاستهداف الروسي
المستمر والذي يتكثف حاليا في اوديسايف
بالاضافه الى ما حصل مساء من خلال القصف
على خركات هو يهدف الى نقطه رئيسيه ترتبط
بملف الحبوب تصدير الحبوب عمليا امين
المجلس الاعلى للدفاع والامن في اوكرانيا
لخص كيفيه قراءه السلطات الاوكرانيه لكل
هذه التطورات التي حصلت خلال الساعات
الماضيه لاسيما اطلاق تسعه عشر صاروخا من
قبل القوات الروسيه باتجاه اوديسا واعلان
القوات الاوكرانيه اسقاط تسعه منها بينما
وصلت 10 اخرى الى اهدافها امين مجلس الامن
القومي تحدث في اوكرانيا عن معطيات رئيسيه
قال بان هذا القصف الروسي المكثف يهدف
اولا الى عزل اوكرانيا عن البحر الاسود
وايضا تدمير البنيه التحتيه المرتبطه
بتصدير الحبوب هو ربط هذا الامر بان
القياده الروسيه تسعى من خلال هذا القصف
المتواصل لهذه المناطق الساحليه الى
ابتزاز الغربي وفق توصيفه من خلال فرض ما
بات يشبه مجاعه عالميه هذا التوصيف
استخدمهم المسؤول الاوكراني معتبرا بان كل
هذا الضغط كل هذا القصف محاولات عزل
اوكرانيا عن البحر الاسود تهدف الى اجلاس
القوى الغربيه مع روسيا للتواصل الى
اتفاقيه تسمح برفع مجموعه من العقوبات
وتحول روسيا الى المصدر الاول للحبوب في
العالم وبالتالي ضمن هذه القراءه تعتبر
السلطات الاوكرانيه بانه ينبغي العمل على
تامين ممر امن لتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
وضمن هذا السياق تضع الاستهداف المباشر
لما تقول بانها البنى التحتيه في اوديسا
وفي ميكوليف لكل الموانئ التي يمكن ان
تستخدمها اوكرانيا لتصدير الحبوب ضمن هذا
السياق يمكن ان نفهم ايضا ما حصل خلال
ايام فاضيه من خلال التاكيد عبر الاتصالات
التي قام بها مع مجموعه من الدول الغربيه
وفي طلعتها مسؤولين في النيتو على ضروره
العمل على تامين الممرات باتجاه تصدير
الحبوب لانه يعتبر بان هذا الامر حيوي جدا
ليس فقط بالنسبه للصادرات الاوكرانيه ولكن
ايضا للمجهود الحربي العام الذي تخوده
اوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا وهي تحتاج بشكل
ماس الى تصدير الحبوب طيب نتابع وجهه
النظر الروسيه مازن هنا مع نور الدين
الدغير حول هذا الموضوع حول
الجبهه الجنوبيه وما يجري في البحر الاسود
اضافه الى طبعا التطورات الميدانيه شرقا
نور الدين معنا من دونات
نعم احسنت هي طبيعه المعركه القائمه في
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا ربما تعطي
تغيرا في طبيعه ومساحه المواجهات ما بين
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه ربما
اذا ما حاولنا ان نتلمس طبيعه المواجهه
الحاليه ربما قد نشهد اختلاف للتكتيكات
والاستراتيجيات مثلا اذا انطلقنا من هنا
من دونيسك التي نتواجد فيها لا تتوقف
القذائف سواء تلك التي تنطلق من المناطق
التابعه والخاضعه للقوات الروسيه والمؤيده
لها هنا في دنيتك او سقوط قذائف قادمه من
المناطق التي تتواجد فيها القوات
الاوكرانيه اذا ما حاولنا رصد القذائف
التي تصل من الجهه الاوكرانيه ربما لا يصل
لا تختلف الفتره الزمنيه ما بين عشر دقائق
في وصول قضاف الى مجموعه من المناطق من
بتروسكي كيروسكي كل هذه المناطق ربما تعطي
انطباعا على ان ساحه المواجهات على الاقل
في هذه الحدود هي ساحه مواجهات مفتوحه
ربما تحاول الاوكرانيه اختراق المزيد ربما
يعرف بالهجوم المضاده وهنا نتحدث عن
مساحات سواء في بالقرب من او بالقرب من
مارينكا الان تتحدث السلطات الروسيه هنا
على ان القوات الاوكرانيه حاولت القيام
بالعديد من
الهجمات المضاده لاستهداف القوات الروسيه
في منطقه وفي محيط منطقه باخموت وكذلك في
مجموعه من المناطق المحيطه هنا
لكن الحديث الروسي هنا يتحدث على ان
القوات الروسيه بشكل باي شكل من الاشكال
حاولت ان تصد هذا الهجوم ربما هنا يدخل
ضمن الاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه وهي محاوله
قدم المزيد من المساحات في اطار ما يعرفه
بالعمليه المضاده لكن حسن هذا لا يعني ان
القوات الروسيه هنا في هذه المناطق تكتفي
بمنطق الدفاع لكن في مناطق اخرى تحاول ان
تخلق ما يمكن ان نصطلح عليه بمنطق الهجوم
الذي ربما قد يكون منه هو احداث خرق في
صفوف القوات الاوكرانيه وهنا نتحدث عن
منطقه خركيب يتم الحديث على ان القوات
الروسيه استعملت انواع مختلفه من الاسلحه
استعملت طائرات الصخور 35 وطائرات
والمدفعيات وكذلك يمكن الحديث عن الهجوم
عن اوديسا وعن لكن ربما القراءه الروسيه
في الهجوم على مجموعه من المناطق هنا
نتحدث عن اوديسا وعن الحديث هنا هو محاوله
استهداف مواقع الذخيره مواقع تمركز القوات
الاوكرانيه مواقع الامداد للقوات
الاوكرانيه المتقدمه على الجبهه الروسيه
وذلك لاحداث خلخله في الاستراتيجيه
العسكريه الاوكرانيه وعدم احداث اي خرق في
مساحات اخرى داخل الاراضي الروسيه ربما
هذا قد يكون منطلق لدى القوات الروسيه على
الاقل في حدود المواجهه سواء في سواء في
على الحدود مع من اجل كسب الوقت او ربما
للبحث عن فرصه للحصول على مزيد من مساحه
اخرى من دون ك نور الدين غير مراسل
الجزيره شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا لمازن
ابراهيم مراسل الجزيره من سلوفيا